Speaker 1: Let's start today with the latest on
the pandemic in the United States and around the
world, then I want to look at the question Do any
religions actually prohibit vaccination for all
of the talk about? I have a religious exemption
from being vaccinated. What religions ban being
vaccinated? If any, we're going to look at that in
a moment now. Last week I came to you and I said
COVID cases are down 53 percent in the U.S. from
their Delta Peak. Deaths are down 33 percent in
the U.S. from their Delta Peak. That was last
week, and we said, what will the next week
look like? Well, it's now next week relative to
last week, and the numbers are once again better.
Let's look at those numbers and see just how much
better the U.S. average daily COVID cases are now
down 59 percent from their delta wave peak of
167 thousand a day, the U.S. now seeing 68000
cases per day. Yes, it's a crazy number, but it's
the lowest it's been since late July. And for now,
it's pointing down rather than pointing up.
And that's a good thing. In terms of daily
U.S. deaths, the delta wave peak was all the way
back up to just a hair under 2000 deaths a day.
That is now down to about 1275 deaths a day,
a tragic number but a decline of 35 percent.
So both cases and deaths declining in the
last week. Cases declining more than deaths
on a percentage basis. OK, what's the global
context? What's happening globally? Well,
globally, cases are actually going back up. This
is being led by some specific countries, which
I'll tell you about in a moment. But globally,
cases have gone up. It's not a big change,
but cases. Globally, we're down to about 400 3000
a day. They're now back up to 400 and 16000 a day.
It's a small change, but it could be meaningful.
It could mean one of two things. Number one,
we could be seeing the start of another wave with
winter coming to the northern hemisphere. That's
a possibility. It could just be a blip. We don't
know yet, but this is being led by some countries
with major increases in cases last week. I'll
give you some examples. The Czech Republic has
gone from like they were almost at zero, that
they had 150 cases a day. They're at 3000 a day,
150 to 3000 a day. That's a huge spike in the
Czech Republic. And when I tell you the other
countries where we're seeing increases, you'll
start to notice a regional trend. Hungary, Poland,
Slovenia are seeing big spikes. Hungary went from
70 cases a day to 2000. Poland went from 150 cases
a day to 5000. Slovenia went from 60 cases a
day, all the way up to about 1750. Just those
few countries already. That's a major increase.
And you look at the others Slovakia, Croatia,
Ukraine all seeing significant increases in cases.
So it could be that area. Also, big concerns in
the United Kingdom. At one point last week,
the United Kingdom had the highest case rate.
I believe in the world now, stabilizing at a very
bad number of 45000 cases a day in the U.K. That's
all bad. So the question is, is that coming to the
U.K., we're coming to the U.S. Rather, we saw with
Delta that it started in Europe and then we were
just lagging behind. I think it was like six to
eight weeks or something like that. So is what's
happening in some of these European countries now
going to be here in six or eight weeks? We just
don't know yet. You can find opinion saying yes,
you can find opinion saying no. One view
is we are going to see a decline and we are
going to get to sort of like endemic
levels where you get yourself vaccinated.
If you do or participate in indoor events with a
bunch of people, maybe everybody gets tested. I've
been to a couple of events, including a birthday
party where that was the protocol. That's what
we were getting down to that endemic level. The
other view is this is about to explode as we
head into winter in the United States. What do
we know about the U.S. right now? We know that
vaccination is basically flat at a very low level.
We're doing about 800000 vaccinations per day,
with reports indicating that there
are more third doses in those 800k
than first doses. That's very, very bad. We
know that we are believed to be very close
to vaccine approval for five to 11 year olds and
FDA panel recommending that approval yesterday.
And now we're just waiting for broader approval.
It could be that we start vaccinating five to 11
year olds as soon as next Friday. That's that's
something we're following. We know that schools
where you are not required to wear. Masks are
seeing significantly higher COVID case rates
than those where you are, so masks continue
to be relevant for those unvaccinated kids.
Also new The CDC is now saying that some
immunocompromised people can and should get
a fourth COVID shot. That is not something that
was previously discussed in any great detail.
And now the CDC is saying, yeah, it's not just a
third dose for some immunocompromised people. We
should be looking and even starting to do fourth
doses. So we're going to follow all of this
cases down here. But increasing globally. And
the question is, are we headed for a very dark
winter or are we headed for a not so bad winter
with things being essentially everything open?
Some places with vaccine requirements, some
places vaccine or testing requirements,
et cetera, as we've been seeing, so we will
continue to follow it. We'll see where we are
by next week. We could either be at 60 percent
down from the Delta Peak or we could start to
see a turnaround, which would not be very good.